people don't talk to their neighbors at
all anymore exactly I actually talked to
mine and it's nice but there's some on
my blog I haven't talked to because
they're just completely anti-social but
it's because of the internet of course
it is so I knew everybody on my blog
before the internet everybody now think
about this
AOC is not representative of the average
Democrat or average American she is
fringe leftist she's becoming more chill
establishment she gets elected because
she goes online and typically if you
were like a fringe leftist weirdo you'd
go outside and wave your weird leftist
flag and everyone would be like Sean
shun and you'd be like okay this is not
working now those people go online and
every person in every different part of
the country forms a community of ten
thousand and they share resources and
they organize and they they gain power
in this way I mean same can be said for
even this show we gain power from
everyone from all different all over the
world all over the country coming
together and watching and supporting us
this allows Fringe ideas to become
prominent now think about what it's
going to be like with AI